ضعني في هذا الجانب لأن
آخر فكرة قد أتخلى عنها في المرة الأخيرة التي
جئت فيها إلى هنا ، صاحب السعادة ،
كان هذا موقعًا للبناء كان كله
رمال صحراوية وتلك الأشجار هناك
التي هي عبارة عن مجموعة من الأشجار الحرفية التي
كان عمرها حوالي 80 عامًا كانت الوحيدة  شيء
قياسي ، كل شيء بنيناه سيبقى
بعد انتهاء المعرض ، لذا بطريقة
نبني مدينة المستقبل ، نحن
فقط نتأكد من أنها يجب أن
تستوعب معرضًا عالميًا لمدة ستة
أشهر في عام 2020 اليوم أقف أمامك
من أجل النفس إلى
وزير الدولة الإماراتي للتعاون الدولي
ريمو هاشمي كان في
مقعد القيادة في إكسبو 2020
منذ بدء المشاريع الضخمة منذ
أن أصبحت دبي أول
مدينة في الشرق الأوسط تفوز بحق
استضافة العالم
[موسيقى
] أعدني إلى عملية
تجميع العطاء والفوز
بالمزايدة في حمد الله 27 نوفمبر
2013 ، رزقت بطفلي البالغ من العمر ثلاثة أشهر ،
لقد فزنا وكانت لحظة رائعة
في الوقت المناسب  يبلغ أكبر عمر لديك الآن
ستة وستة وستة أشهر وثلاثة أشهر ، كم عدد الأشخاص
الذين شاركوا حتى الآن في
البناء ، لذلك من طموح هذا الموقع
لدينا أربعة وأربعون ألف عامل
من حيث ساعات العمل لدينا حوالي
مائة  وثلاثين مليون ساعة عمل ، لذلك
قدر كبير من الاهتمام حقًا
برفاهية عمالنا ، لقد بحثنا
عن كثب في ضمان أن
تكون معايير الصحة والسلامة من الدرجة الأولى كما هي
بعد كل أبطال هذا المشروع
[الموسيقى]
لقد مضى عام واحد  بعيدًا عن الترحيب
بالزوار الأوائل لهذا الموقع ، إطلعني
على التحديات الرئيسية
المتبقية حتى يكون هذا الموقع جاهزًا
للترحيب بهؤلاء الزوار ، سيكون الموقع
جاهزًا للتحدي الآن المضي قدمًا
كيف تتأكد من أنه عندما
يأتي الزائرون إلى هنا؟  أنت تخلق ذكريات ،
فأنت تضمن لأول
مرة أن معرضًا عالميًا قد وصل إلى هذا الجزء
من العالم قد جف
إلى UE. كيف تتأكد من أن الأشخاص الذين
يزورون هذا الجزء ونتوقع زيارة 25 مليون
ابتعد قائلين يا إلهي يا
لها من فرصة في العمر
نستمتع بها حقًا ولن ننسى أبدًا مدى
صعوبة الحفاظ على
الزخم وراء الكواليس لهذا
المشروع عندما تكون الأوقات أصعب مما
كانت عليه عندما تم إطلاق هذا المشروع
وكيف  هل تضمن 33 مليار
دولار من التأثير الاقتصادي الإيجابي
لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة بعد عام 2030 ، لذا فإننا نلعب
لعبة بيكي الطويلة ، اقتصاديات أو اقتصاديات
دورية بطبيعتها ،
تزداد سوءًا ، تزداد سوءًا
بمرور الوقت على الرغم من أننا وضعناها  وضع
الأساسيات اللازمة لضمان استمرار كوننا
مركزًا مهمًا
إذا كنت ستنتهي بين الشرق والغرب
والشمال والجنوب والجنوب والجنوب ، فهذا
أمر أساسي حقًا للتأكد من أن هذا ليس
فيلًا أبيض وقد كانت هناك
حالات في الماضي  من خلال الخبرة
التي لم تنجح للتو ، ما الذي
تعلمته من البلدان الأخرى التي تقيم هذا
المعرض العالمي وكيف يمكنك تجنب
هذه المزالق ، لذلك خططنا لعام 2013
نظرنا في ما  المدينة والأشياء
التي لا تمتلكها الدولة ،
نحضر المترو إلى هنا ، وننقل المؤتمر
في المعرض الموجود حاليًا في
وسط مدينة دبي هنا ولكننا أيضًا
لا نفد صبر بيكي ، فنحن ندرك أن
هذه ليست مثل مفاتيح التبديل  بحاجة
إلى تطوير عضويًا ، فنحن نضع
نظامًا يساعد في دعم الشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة ، فنحن
نبحث في كيفية المساعدة في دعم صناعة
FinTech ،
وهذا كله في Legacy ونحن
نستخدم Expo كنقطة انطلاق
لبعض هذه الأشياء  موضوع
يربط العقول لخلق مستقبل ثم
تصميمه لتعزيز روح
الإبداع والابتكار وليس فقط
في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة في منطقة تعاني من
السياسات المتعثرة ، تقول إن إكسبو 2020
سيكون سياسيًا تشارك فيه إيران
وكذلك إسرائيل وقطر مدعوون من
الجميع  ونأمل أن
يأتوا جميعًا. قناعتنا أن
هذه المنطقة بحاجة وأن هذه المنطقة
ذات مرة وأن هذه المنطقة تستحق
الاستقرار والتقدم ونأمل
ألا نتطلع إلى عائد على الاستثمار.  estment
في المعرض نفسه لأنه بُني
لفترة أطول من ذلك بكثير
ورؤيته تتعدى نطاقك إلى أبعد من
[الموسيقى]